[Music]
okay so here's a question we know the
answer to what's the point of american
intel agencies couldn't be clearer in
the law
the point of an american intel agency is
to monitor what happens in other
countries and then report back to the
present united states so that he can
make better decisions about u.s foreign
policy period that's why we have the cia
that's the only reason we do these
agencies are not allowed to spy on
american citizens because that would
invalidate democracy
but they're doing it on a huge scale
and they're doing it on direct orders
from the biden administration not a
conspiracy theory it's verified it's
true
now new legislation from congress seeks
to stop that this legislation has been
introduced by congressman chris stewart
of utah the congressman joins us now to
explain congressman first of all thank
you so much for doing this this is
illegal nobody seems to care we should
care um what would your legislation do
well to emphasize what you've already
said tucker the the whole purpose of the
ic intelligence community nsa cia and
others is to concentrate on foreign
threats foreign terrorism of four nation
states russia china north korea
it was never ever intended that they
would look at u.s persons until
this administration comes along and says
you know those other threats are
important but the real threat we're
worried about is domestic violent
extremism dves they call them white
supremacy and because this white
supremacy threat is so great which by
the way is nonsense
but by their thinking
because this is such a great theft now
we need to use the power the awesome
tools that we give the national security
agency or the cia or the dia we're
compelled to use those upon you as
persons the administration says
and that's why you have a situation like
about a year ago where the office of
director of national intelligence not
the fbi not homeland security the dni
using the tools of the national
counterterrorism center provides a
briefing to congress on what white
supremacy on domestic terrorism it
should enrage americans that they would
think that they would allow them to use
this awesome power hey if you think you
want to build an american kgb if you
think that's a good idea then keep going
down this road but if you think it's a
it's a horrible fearsome idea
then then please work with me i'm
talking now my members of congress
please work with me to try and stop it
so they've spied on this show they've
admitted it i've spoken directly to two
sitting members of congress whose job it
is to oversee the intelligence agency
who told me directly that they were
being spied on by the intel agencies and
they didn't do anything about it i
wonder how many members of congress are
too intimidated to to push back the
powers of these agencies
well i guess we're going to find out
but you know and it's not just members
of the press i mean we know that the cia
and director brennan lied about it when
they were spying on members of the
senate i mean for heaven's sakes tucker
if the last four or five years have
taught us anything it has surely taught
us that senior members the fbi and
department of justice clearly were
deceptive to congress deceptive to the
fisa courts deceptive to the american
people
and now once again they want to increase
that ability to enhance that ability by
drawing in these other agencies
and at once again
it there's no reason for it there's no
need for it by the way there's enough
terror threats and other threats for
them to it's not like they've got extra
bandwidth like they don't have anything
to do
and very clearly uh the department of
justice and fbi that's their
responsibility not the cia not the nsa
exactly so nicely put we are rooting for
you congressman chris stewart hope
you'll come back and let us know who
didn't vote for this that'll be
interesting thank you very much thank
you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight